the stark reality is that britain can
and must do more to rise to this
horrific challenge the inescapable facts
are that the taliban won and we lost but
we had previously promised that the
military withdrawal would not be
followed by economic and political
withdrawal
indeed in 2010 when we announced the end
of the combat role for british troops we
doubled aid in development spending from
the uk as we had promised
now while the 286 million pounds pledged
recently is extremely welcome it is
still not clear over what period it is
all being spent and whether it is new
and additional funding it is however
clear that it is not enough the
tremendous response to the disaster and
emergency committees appeal for
afghanistan in december shows too that
the british people do not think it is
enough as once again ordinary citizens
across britain have responded
magnificently
the appalling reports from brave
journalists like christina lamb cannot
be read mr speaker without tears of
anguish of the plight of our fellow
human beings
selling their daughters into early
marriage to provide food for their
families partying with body organs to
feed their family that isn't this is not
science fiction mr speaker these are
facts attested to by british journalists
and charities working on the ground
while the world food program is trying
desperately to feed 20 million starving
people mr speaker ninety percent of the
people in afghanistan do not have enough
to eat five million are living in camps
four million are just over the border in
iran and they won't stay there mr
speaker they will be heading for europe
and for britain before long
um professionals have made clear that
4.4 billion dollars is required and
typically fair burden sharing would mean
the uk would agree to do around 10 of
this mr speaker why is the uk not
hosting this important and welcome
pledging conference in march before the
prime minister decided mr speaker to
vaporize differed there were dedicated
officials steeped in the practicalities
respected across the world who were able
to bring together the necessary
technical skills connections and
experience to lead the international
community to a better and more
responsible place as britain's
international development secretary i
spent half my time mr speaker urging
pleading and cajoling my counterparts in
the rich world to step up to the plate
britain led and the international
community followed we need the same umph
the same vigor from britain today to
make this happen it's not just an appeal
to our humanity mr speaker it's firmly
and completely in our own national
interest